all right a few days before Christmas in
Torrance California robbers tried to
pull off a smash and grab robbery at a
jewelry store inside a nearby Recruiting
Station a marine and an applicant along
with several bystanders they heard the
commotion and very quickly the group of
Good Samaritans detained the
perpetrators
[Music]
let's go
simplify
salute
that's why homie put it down for the
America
almost all the jewelry has been
recovered one of the people who helped
detain the robbers was a marine staff
sergeant Jose fragoso and he joins us
now Jose good to see you and I got to
tell you what fantastic video you and
one of the applicants to the Marines
stepped into gear tell us what happened
yes sir good evening uh so what
initially happened is that I heard a
bunch of glass breaking and when I did
the first response was to go check out
Dan's jewelry I I know there were just
two doors down I had to make sure
everything was all right as I approached
the uh the jewelry store I saw four
individuals that were robbing the story
they had a sledgehammer there uh once
once they were coming out I was able to
apprehend one of the one of the suspects
uh with applicant in mind was able to
apprehend another one and between uh a
couple of us and bystanders we actually
were able to detain two of the four for
the police to come by and just take them
take them away Jose I imagine that the
uh the the the criminals here didn't
intend to meet Marines as they were
trying to do this Smash and grab did
they seem surprised that there was a
group of you that were going to step
into gear and stop this burglary in the
process absolutely yeah I don't think
they definitely expected to have
individuals in uniform uh stop them that
weren't uh police officers yeah no no
doubt and good for you guys so you're an
applicant actually in your office at the
time you said uh who was applying to to
join the Marines is has he been admitted
what's his status right now
currently he's still in the process sir
so he's uh enlisting right now we are
currently just wearing waiting on a
couple of different things to continue
his process uh but he definitely will be
enlisting and so you said that in regard
to the jewelry store all the jewelry got
back and I think if I got the story
right two of the two of the criminals
were apprehended by you guys but did two
get away and were they later apprehended
how did that work
yes sir so two end up getting away I'm
not really sure about the background of
it I I know we were able to detain two
I'm not sure the police uh police
officer were able to take the other two
as well okay and and your superiors did
they support you spring into action
because sometimes I'm not sure where the
military goes on issues like this
obviously you're a recruiter but also
you're an American and a Good Samaritan
you you saw this happen are your
superiors uh happy with what you've done
have you been commended for your action
yep yes they were sir they were
absolutely very happy uh they they
thanked me they said it's the Marine
thing to do to make sure we uphold our
own values you know I can say what it's
always great to have Marines around I
mean I love in the video they were
yelling Semper Fi to you it's like all
right I got I got some family and
support around as I'm stepping in and
protecting this business staff sergeant
Jose fragoso thanks for joining me and
thanks for your great bravery and thanks
for your service to the country
appreciate it thank you for having me
sir I appreciate it all right subscribe
to the Fox News YouTube channel to catch
our nightly opens stories that are
changing the world and changing your
life from Tucker Carlson tonight